exactement pascal ça a l'air d'être un
jour avec la transmission marche j'ai à
mes côtés le président de l'uci m m il
le dit mieux que moi philippe guerry
bonjour bonjour alors lui qui m aime
c'est quoi alors seule union des
industries mécaniques et métallurgiques
voilà une filière qui peine à séduire à
recruter notamment chez les jeunes le
qualifier les compétences qui sont
pointues sur tous les métiers moderne et
technologies modernes c'est qsi
intéressant pour les jeunes et c'est
pour ça que le jeu à laquelle on assiste
aujourd'hui c'est justement pour donner
envie aux jeunes voilà donner envie aux
jeunes leur faire connaître vraiment ce
qu'on fait dans des usines ce qu'on fait
dans un entreprise et comment ça
fonctionne
alors ça vous le fait déjà depuis
longtemps et là vous avez décidé de
tenter une nouvelle expérience deux
occasions une escape game est
aujourd'hui une enquête policière dans
le cadre de la semaine de l'industrie
oui c'est des idées qui sont nés dans
l'équipe la lui ai même côte-d'or
d'ailleurs on est on est vraiment
novateur en france à ce niveau là donc à
cette enquête policière ou les jeunes
doivent découvrir qui a volé les plans
d'une un véhicule autonome dans un grand
groupe automobile s'est très secret
parce que la voiture est relancé sur un
salon est quelqu'un voulait les plans
donc il va falloir qu'ils trouvent ça en
passant à travers différents services de
l'entreprise il y aura bureaux
d'étudiants la production y aura les
services contrôle qualité de service
tous ces services sont transversaux on y
retrouve un peu dans toutes les
entreprises
donc ça leur fait connaître un peu
comment fonctionne une entreprise de
l'intérieur avec des technologies
modernes ils vont avoir des des
appareils pour aller chercher les les
empreintes digitales des choses comme ça
dans le clip on est là quel est le
rapport avec l'industrie du coup ben
c'est vraiment un problème industriel
parce qu' ils passent à travers les
services y passent à travers l'homme ils
passent à travers le bureau d'études à
travers le service ressources humaines
ont qu'ils voient comment d'embauché les
gens comment les gens font
carrière dans l'industrie comment ils
travaillent donc c'est leur donner envie
et leur faire découvrir ce qui se passe
tous les jours dans l'entreprise
alors là on le voit ce sont des 4e et
ils sont en train d'enquêter en fait on
se rend pas compte mais on découvre la
vie est peut-être son futur métier
voilà on découvre tous les métiers qui a
dans l'entreprise comment les gens ont
été formés comment ils travaillent dans
l'entreprise comment ils peuvent passer
d'un service à l'autre donc ils vont un
peu et puisqu'ils font aussi ce qu'ils
font à l'intérieur d'un service est un
service méthode est un service bureau
d'études il ya de la production dans
quel sens ça fonctionne dans quel sens
les choses s'articule et ça leur donne
envie je pense d'eux alors là on
construit une voiture
les plans ont été volés mais c'est un
peu je penche plus construit on espère
et ils vont un peu tous les gens qui
participent à un même projet donc c'est
vraiment d'être un travail d'équipé dans
une entreprise c'est votre quotidien
saad essayer de dire que les métiers des
industries de la métallurgie c'est plus
le chaudronnier tout crasseux
non alors c'est toujours des
chaudronniers mais il n'ya pas que des
chaudronniers mais surtout avec des
métiers moderne un chaudronnier ça
travaille les robots ça soude avec des
machines automatiques
il ya du contrôle radio qui se fait sur
les pièces il ya plein technologie haute
où il faut faire des plans numériques
faire de là il ya plein technologie qui
intègre le numérique la vision avec la
réalité virtuelle toutes ces choses là
donc les jeunes vont avoir accès à
toutes ces technologies dont il rêve
qu'il voit chez eux sur leur smartphone
mais ils vont les avoir en réel dans
l'industrie rapidement pour conclure
samedi ils en ont l'occasion en dehors
du collège vous avez aussi une journée
partout oui alors samedi on a un forum
c'est l'industrie recrutent ou là y'a
plus de 100 entreprises qui vont avoir
leurs offres d'emploi et là ils peuvent
venir les tout le monde peut venir le
grand public avec leurs parents ils vont
voir une centaine d'offres d'emploi en
une demi journée en un seul lieu ils
vont pouvoir rencontrer les recruteurs
et discuter directement avec les
recruteurs donc là c'est vraiment
l'occasion pour de voir plein de postes
ouverte
merci président et n'oubliez par ce sont
des filières qui recrutent les jeunes et
ce sont des métiers passionnants